[Musique]
venture est né en 1979 à ottawa au
moment de l'élection des
progressistes-conservateurs de joe clark
vingt ans plus tard il fait ses premiers
pas en politique en participant au
congrès de l'alternative uni une
coalition de conservateurs qui donnera
naissance à l'alliance canadienne
il va travailler alors avec le chef
stockwell day en 2004 après la fusion de
l'alliance canadienne et du parti
progressiste conservateur
indochine se joint à la nouvelle
formation il se présente en saskatchewan
où à la surprise générale il évince le
néo-démocrate leur live from député de
regina-qu'appelle depuis trois décennies
en 2011 sous le gouvernement de stephen
harper il devient à 32 ans le plus jeune
président de la chambre des communes de
l'histoire six ans plus tard il
deviendra chef du parti conservateur
coiffant maxime bernier au fil d'arrivée
après 13 tours de scrutin